petit point ramenant la retraite
progressive madame le pen
marine le pen mais c'est flou il ya un
tableau qui chaque amour c'est un
décalage parents n'arrivent et moi j'ai
expliqué avec sa 35 milliards nous vous
rappelons éclair s'émerveille nous
sommes les gars 18 ans il sait faire la
même chose que ce qu'on a fait pendant
les événements on a fait cette économie
même s'il vous plaît pendant les cinq
ans nous fait avec léa les gardiens du
temps et de la tenue merci ce n'est rien
tu le sais bien
le temps pas si ce n'est
tu sais bien parce qu'un débat comme
celui de ce soir peut changer la donne
ce qu'il peut influencer le vote de
dimanche prochain le changer alors pour
le moment emmanuel macron a donnés
vainqueurs dans les sondages avec plus
de 10 points d'écart sur son adversaire
vaudoyer 56 contre 44 % des voix et
aucun débat dans le passé n'a modifié
l'ordre d'arrivée projeté dans les
enquêtes d'opinion cela dit certains
effets peut tout de même se faire
ressentir et la madame le pen emmanuel
base est opposé marine le mien et place
un système de chômage partiel qui a
protégé nos emplois l'industrie on l'a
fait comme ça mails alors sa forme assez
mal avec la peine si nous étions maîtres
d'école ce que nous ne sommes pas nous
vous donnions que j'ai alors vu nos
rêves je vous en prie revenions
échauffent l'école
alors on prend la responsabilité de
tirer le penalty voilà et c'est pas
personne merveilleuse
je demande la barre de ce penalty de
jean-michel zumba mais d'un autre
handisport qu'on voit la chute un
hall des expos
mais non ça tu mets pas ça jamais tu
mets ça c'est une blague
l'émail qui nettoie les toilettes sont
aussi celles qui font la cuisine merci
non non mais sans déconner mais c'est
quoi ce restaurant
tu génitaux avec toilettes et après tu
vas fallait pizza quoi
votre programme la nique aux ni tête cet
égard puisque vous vous proposez une
baisse pérenne comme vous l'avez dit sur
les hydrocarbures énergie fossile très
polluante juste par cohérence vos
propres et 2e chaude bon moi je
considère que là on a sonné sur une
controverse clair plus votre projet il
est très transparent vous êtes climato
sceptiques ou mettez les mains sûres sur
l'arbre et on peut poser le front en
fait juste sur l'arbre
comme quand on fait un bon massage qui
détend je suis absolument pas climato
sceptiques
en aucun cas mais vous vous êtes un peu
klimato hypocrite d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être pour ça que les gens ne
croient pas à votre volonté de régler
tous ces problèmes là je veux dire
pourquoi ils ont raison d'ailleurs j'ai
lu la tribune des manuels macron ma
france c'est très bien y a rien à dire
dans le figaro c'est très bien gergovie
on peut parler de valby ça très bien
paroles et paroles et paroles et du
blabla et du blabla et du blabla pendant
les onze
qui mange tes parents les ont surpris
les parties
commencent en tous cas une personne
n'écoute
et enfin à brussels a fait une bêtise et
je crois qu'il pourra pas trop compter
sur la solidarité de sa soeur et mon
fils a encore admis la plaque qu'est ce
qu'on va faire de toi qu'est-ce qu'on
fait cette fois ci
on a une question si vous le voulez bien
sur la laïcité
puisque le temps qu'office discipline et
qui vit à 5 heures en mode veille c'est
vrai ou témoin qu'ont vieillir
je crois que c'est factuel je serai très
respectueux à votre égard vous ça ne se
voit pas moi j'ai peur que ça se voit
beaucoup madame